I was going bros my name is welcome back
to a new episode this half-life the
single kid the best channel 6 it is a
good idea actually there I have to be
emo oh yes I guess finds one of them
oh man I remember the [ __ ] episode oh
man it's so worldly oh yeah the
Halloween jammer what was they it was so
brutal I remember and I was like a kid
huh holy [ __ ] [ __ ] it was like a years I
sign well that was easy
circumcision everyone is happy except
the penis
okay let's get out of this [ __ ]
stupid ass clothes man
oh yeah we just need to go in here well
that was easy
[Music]
okay then let's go back now should be
easy right there's something really
weird Josh said I wanted to fire on them
nice pose breath all right why are we
okay is that probably we need to go in
here - oh we need to go back - Randy
it's a bit confusing at this points to
someone [ __ ] going on what's this so
recording there's data on here did they
say anything what kind of Taco Bell is
it going to be we finished building it
Shh all right we're gonna have to
completely obliterate everything in a
three-block radius what that Georgia's
Underground to blow up the area and bury
it all then make a fake story about an
earthquake you're gonna just blow up
three blocks sons of [ __ ]
[Music]
what gives them the right I knew there
was more to this it's not a simple Taco
Bell we're dealing with it's the most
massive Taco Bell ever built
you see ever since the whole Doritos
Locos Tacos thing Taco Bell thinks they
could do whatever they want well not
here not in our town you've done well
new kid we're not going to let Taco Bell
win I'll take that picture you wanted
now view with the PTA
[ __ ] yeah nice I'll send it to you
finally I wonder if there they're gonna
get sued for using Taco Bell probably
and they probably don't give a [ __ ] okay
finally we can talk to the [ __ ] Goths
goddamn I get so lost some time in this
game here we go
whoa he did it nice yeah buddy for me
all not goth they'll have to pass the
final test you might look goth Frodo but
can you dance goth no I can [ __ ] ya game
[Applause]
why you call that smoking car I'm
feeling the rage
shut up Matty a I'm balancing here I'd
like what you did with your coffee then
we do it now what do you think it's
pretty goth he's pretty coughed right
yeah pretty good I felt his pain alright
okay I'm officially proving yourself
yeah they're just tell us where you need
us and we'll be there
I think any Vikings that's offensive to
me okay that's not very cough that it
may be out the [ __ ] Jesus so I get to
choose to fight for humans already for
else I want to fight for humans because
we started off with it and I generally
don't really like I don't know what
awesome I don't wanna fight these guys
don't want ballads it's not gonna be
what is this swirling doom okay whoa
wasn't that great
Oh from hezekiah is awesome okay what is
he doing choose their fate okay
[Music]
if you ever want some work done on your
nose see dr. Tom he's the best hi you
have returned
come stare douche bag it's time to
summon our forces simply call them here
and your dedication to Koopa cape will
be complete climb the signal tower sir
douche bag call forth your new recruits
[Music]
I had to do it every one of you have
been to your respective arses sir
douchebag has gone out and brought help
to our kingdom
Suroosh baguette is time to finally give
you a title worthy of your deeds by the
power of mandalas third born of the red
God and by the glory of trash I hereby a
noisy commander tooth bag with all the
rights and privileges accompanies Devon
what are those yeah I'll hit miss desk
citizens after the kid we know where
they're hiding the stick I told you they
were cheating now we shall march on the
school and make the hallways drip with
havin life ah
it is what I said that he becomes more
joyful oh that's hilarious
oh [ __ ] what's going on thank you for
your courage and your in joining our
fact tonight we are no longer than
humans or the Goths tonight we unite as
one I feel like such a homo sapien right
now the humans are here they blew their
horns blow our dividers for two guys
make left God's kids prepare to attack
from the hat
what what if the do is gonna do up to
their old tricks again find another way
in take out the barricade from the head
alright and I guess I go this way as if
I need that oh they're already dead and
[ __ ] why the hell did I get this spear
from what the [ __ ]
oh holy Lance awesome okay
ready to do this [ __ ] come on I hurt my
[ __ ] ankle man it hurts like [ __ ]
it's about us do something about this
hey I'm healed except for on the inside
how else would you heal we locked it so
nobody else could get in here no thanks
go kick their ass or douche a lot I did
my job I'm gonna sit here and smoke I
did my job I'm gonna sit here and smoke
I did my job I'm gonna sit here and
smoke yeah but I want to go job I'm
gonna stay here and shop we cleared the
way to the door you did the rest
yeah well I'm tryna anti I did my job
oh this story oops I knew that
[Music]
shapow mown all right let's find some
dirty of [ __ ] I'd say there are [ __ ]
Jessica they're hot yeah what the [ __ ]
what does he wine
why doesn't really matter this game suck
get to the lobby Frank their defenses
hey 20 people shut up down there not
really dad calm down
okay they're probably dead
[Music]
that's going here finally no what's the
[ __ ] what is he doing here
stay back you guys something is
seriously wrong with the hallway
monitors help please That's Gary Neal
she don't touch him he's ginger we came
to school the morning after the
earthquake to report for duty we didn't
know school had been canceled we heard a
sound from down here found this green
goo it was everywhere
it changed the other hallway monitor
serves you right for being a padi
hallway monitor in the first day green
goo make did your hallway monitor is
even neighbor oh [ __ ] look at Snell [ __ ]
that means nice in Swedish they don't
look very nice that a food tray they
became ginger Sammy's the most powerful
kind of zombie let's keep going oh gosh
so much green goo that's my enterprise
shut up nowadays so annoying
ain't nobody here though II not now oh
okay we can go there now I guess you can
take two routes probably oh okay I got
it
don't touch it but us the same guess
what I think we now I want to kill him
with the electric rocket damn it I could
have used that now we gotta fight him in
[ __ ] yes show does tie nice titties
it's a candid look actually
well he died seeing some nice titties
so I guess it's okay okay I want to see
yeah what can you see I'm sorry all
right let's see what he got yes a
unicorn Prince's summons a magical
unicorn sounds wonderful oh come on
don't touch me ginger oh god oh [ __ ]
that's awesome oh hey Kenny hope you're
okay I want to see that unicorn si again
I could have fought it well takes one to
know I don't know what came in Michigan
was a little harder maybe just a lil oh
man no they got our our samples [ __ ] oh
wait that's right that's a reference
isn't it from remember can we exit maybe
oh that's it we're breached battle
stations flaming dodge [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
the shooting [ __ ] sake
oh there's the teleport I didn't see
yeah you're like some flaming dog [ __ ]
yeah hi douchebag there we go
how much dog shift Kennedy can you say
come on man now it's done man
oh come on okay cool finally what
awesome
[ __ ] yeah as Cartman hey hey okay good
douchebag man to catapult guys in the
front not everyone bought it Roger sir
let's go
whoa use your magic to open up my door
I'm trying
[ __ ] yeah baby no what's happened
oh yeah it's level ten tooth he's not
gonna do [ __ ] he's gonna run up for the
steak
this here new kid let's see you handle
both of us got him
no no nuts [ __ ] he's gonna have
molesting such a cute cigar
all right let's circumcise no wait let's
debuff them or she has a lot of helps
then we're doggy all right it's time for
Kenny to use the best attack in the
world they bus kawaii all right be ready
I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready
yes now what I think yes
oh [ __ ] the mouse yes they did the dog
died
sorry sure the dog would die O'Shea
Stan is crazy shut up it's okay time to
sling of David they'll both die
yes oh no no no no
why oh [ __ ] I should have waited killing
the dog holy [ __ ] that's badass all
right we're gonna have to heal March 1
yes all right
me we have a lot of peepee let's see
asleep I say 2nd position maybe don't
worry I'm trained for this yeah welcome
now Kenny hurry up
use your kawaii hello he rubs his
nipples first quite excellent yeah oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
let's finish him
and had to be done
gonna have to loot your whole your [ __ ]
sweet so full of [ __ ] man I can I pray
I'm sitting on the toilet taking a huge
smelly dump because I'm big dumb fat ass
[ __ ] ek easy picking
that's great I need to FK I'm gonna do
with this that's how you start a fight
baby
we're so Oh Pierre this is too easy I
think Avenue
laughter till it ain't nothing without
you [ __ ] you up Kyle Oh Becca no oh
[Music]
we got a new friend hi guys
this is it you have the honor of leading
the final assault commander let's tweak
wine now hahaha port sweet where are
they back away that's jus king this dick
doesn't belong with a fat wait that's
liar all right cow you [ __ ] asked for
it go ahead and kick his ass whose bag
new kid common is using you can't you
see it
he's a manipulator you're just jealous
cuz the new kid picked me as a friend of
her you cow you've got one last chance
new kid turn around and fight Cartman
instead do the white thing don't let him
to wash your brain you kid oh my god
I don't know holy this is even a choice
uh well I am do you got a person to be
working for Cartman don't listen to them
douche bag
no you aren't but I really like Kenan
baddest
I gotta have to make this you're gonna
be sorry I haven't seen much of Kyle
kick your ass alright I'm the I wonder
if this will work it would be funny
believing you
please same you know [ __ ] not a nice
tattoo
[Music]
blockage no I didn't wanna have sense
you and I are quite the same but it had
to be done so much black hecho them
again stay yeah it's all about them
d-bus alright the see played doll what
the [ __ ]
[Music]
so you can be burned and frozen at the
same time awesome
[Music]
the [ __ ] is he doing
what the [ __ ]
Oh
ah thank funny free the idea kick it
here that's it the emoji Elton John you
kid got kids take the stick from inside
his desk victory is ours
hey wait a minute our tests don't have
insides Matt Dusk's at the school just
have tabletops no but but Twitter said
whatever here this desk has writing on
it check my locker who's deaf get that
that's that's Clive desk all right blot
West Clyde he took the stick busy
fighting amongst ourselves I built a
kingdom beyond your comprehension I
prayed for a way to destroy you all
the solution came crashing down for that
heavens no it's more that green step
with what I about I shall raise an army
of the duck
[Music]
[Laughter]
but why I banish them to be licensed
space and time and I got pissed a
sandwich dad I'm the ruler of darkness
video whoever controls the stick
controls the universe yes sir so I guess
it doesn't matter which one you Cho boys
Oh
Clyde's out playing in the backyard with
his little friends [ __ ] that [ __ ]
who's these little friends party like
Bieber dolls or some [ __ ] whoa that's
pretty badass yeah you are [ __ ] army
of Darkness defend the fortress
[Music]
what the [ __ ] what the hell are all
those kids O'Shea what the keeper of the
sticks Enzo I'd love to invite you into
my fortress of darkness but I'm afraid
you're too late too late what do you
mean we're too late there you are
butters do you know what time it is
mister it is way past your bedtime oh
dude I'm gonna get it Floyd it's past
your bedtime okay cut again goddamn he
knows our only secret part of you I
don't even know anymore
[Laughter]
I give it up Oprah's enjoy the episode I
just wanted to say you look very nice
today I like with your big video a
little mustache keep it up
unless your ago
and keep it loose and looks fine now
promise you can barely notice can badly
notice just kidding I didn't even see it
haha prophase see ya
[Music]